[Music]
PlayStation 4 owners have been able to
play Ultimate Marvel vs. Capcom 3 since
December but it won't be long until
players on the Xbox one and PC get a
chance to capcom has revealed the game's
release date on the two platforms in
addition to physical versions for ps4
and xbox one I'm Matt and this is your
super powered gamespot news update
Ultimate Marvel vs. Capcom 3 launches
for Xbox one and PC on march seven
they'll be available digitally for
twenty five dollars while the physical
version costs thirty dollars and
includes updated cover art and an
exclusive 10 page comic and if you're
looking for a new game in the crossover
fighting series and you're in luck
marvel vs capcom infinite was announced
in december and is set to release later
this year it features a 2v2 fighting
system as opposed to the series
traditional 3v three matches and the
characters we've seen so far include
Iron Man Captain Marvel Ryu Megaman X
Morgan and Captain America we'll keep
you updated as more characters are
revealed so for that and much more stay
tuned to GameSpot's